chair the defense select committee
tobias elwood is with us now mr elwood
thank you for joining us on the program
we've heard from president
zielinski he feels that the west is not
doing enough and we've heard
from the mayor of kiev who says if you
continue to do business with russia then
you have blood on your hands uh what
more should we be doing
yeah we've we've got to do more we are
doing the right things we're punishing
russia by increasing
international sanctions we're collecting
war crimes evidence we're providing some
weapon systems and ammunition but as i'm
sure we'll hear president zaninsky
articulate when he speaks to the u.n
security council it is all not enough to
alter the immediate course of events and
to stop further genocide from taking
place these images from butcher that
you've just shown are the most barbaric
yeah but we still leave the ukrainians
to do all the heavy lifting we condemn
this slaughter from afar
and we have a little bit of blame there
for when we choose to limit our exposure
for fear of potential escalation we give
putin the green light to exploit our
timidity with ever increasing breaches
of the geneva conventions as the war
crimes clock up and i make it really
clear the key port of odessa is now next
under threat this is was home to over a
million prior to the war it's a critical
lifeline for the rest of the world if it
falls ukraine becomes landlocked and for
russia that will be a success those
vital grain exports we all depend on
will not be able to get out if we want
to avoid another marital we should step
up and task and nato maritime force to
keep the port connected to international
waters that would send a powerful
message to the russians that we are
serious and finally offer the ukrainians
the scale of support that they need
does that not amount to joining the war
we've joined the war already this is
we're in semantics here about weapons
are defensive or offensive
uh it won't end here i've just came back
from poland and germany with the defense
select committee they are upgrading uh
their defense spend because they realize
this is not just about ukraine this is
something bigger going on here that
affects uh european security not just
for now but for the next 10 years or so
and we need to recognize that we need to
uh lean into this and support ukrainians
if putin isn't stopped
now then he'll continue his advance
perhaps not immediately but in a few
years time we need to wake up to this
wider threat
um
as we hear that denmark the foreign
minister telling us that they've
expelled 15 russian diplomats we'll have
to wait to see um what other european
countries do but i know that you served
in bosnia i think back in 1995 when the
srebrenic genocide uh occurred have we
not learned nothing from that
no this is it i mean we used these
phrases never again when i was watching
those scenes i was reminded of my time
in in bosnia when the snow melted in the
in the spring revealing so many bodies
uh everywhere and again the war crimes
teams came in you know to collect those
evidence it took an awful long time uh
to take those people to the hague and i
we need to place this into context we
perhaps have this illusion that somehow
putin will be removed that a coup will
take place or there'll be a purge
again
from my visit to east europe this isn't
going to happen anytime soon putin
because of his messaging that he
controls uh in uh in russia most people
absolutely support what he's doing they
see nato as aggressive they see all
these images that are put down there as
fake news and of course it's a police
state so anybody that shows any dissent
is seen as treachery and this again i
stress is the bigger picture here
there's so much more that we need to do
we are learning fast but we've got to
get better at it
uh
i think was ruled uh as uh genocide in
2004 by the international criminal court
tribunal how much faith do you have
in president putin facing justice
i i really at this moment i don't i
would be amazed if we ever see him uh in
court anytime soon perhaps eventually
one day but there is a bigger picture at
play here the support that he's
receiving
from china is simply
immense he'll be able to distance
himself from what's happening on the
ground i would say that not only are his
soldiers given free reign to do what
they like but there is complete ill
discipline on on the ground themselves
uh which shows
in some of the scenes that you've been
actually uh playing out we shouldn't
hold on to that idea that somehow uh
he's going to be punished any time soon
we have to look for uh more robust
operational ways to support our
ukrainian friends that's exactly what i
think president zielinski will be
calling for when he addresses the united
nations today
okay for now tobias albert thank you
very much indeed thank you